there are no good episode of Power
Rangers and you know it it's one open
time you look ridiculous
oh I look ridiculous yeah look at one of
those freaking playing cards I'm Alice
in Wonderland
you're drumming - j9 you got a mile you
have a giant rubber dinosaur a real
superhero my head don't actively
everyone thank you of my dad looks to me
who must know what I do with that what
is up with that belt
I mean utility anything it's just good
to listen to this list
these are the top five best money more
from Power Ranger up ourselves
yeah number five a different shade of
pink parts one through three from season
three in this finale for Amy Joe
Johnston's Kimberly she meets a famous
gymnastics coach and starts seriously
training for a possible position at the
Pan global games however Rita starts to
make more trouble than usual for the
Rangers which gets in the way of Kim's
training with her status as a ranger
already in jeopardy because of our power
coin falling into the clutches of Zedd
and Rita Kimberly is forced to make a
very difficult decision
Kimberly's farewell is by far the best
handle of the original fives departures
from the show not that there was much
competition she grew into a character
that had some very detailed development
throughout her years as a ranger Kim may
have started out as a bit of a valley
girl stereotype but gradually we saw
more and more about her background and
interests her relationship with Tommy
also added another layer to the
character her goodbye was built up for a
while with the loss of her power coin
prior to these episodes in the end was
obviously near the introduction of her
replacement Kat was also handled very
well as she was a compelling character
from the start by this point she had
free
yourself from Rita's evil spell and was
firmly on the side of the Rangers she
even inspired Kimberly to not give up
and continue training for the Penn
Global's Kat is eventually captured by
Zedd and Rita but her quick thinking
allowed her to escape with the pink
power coin and return it to its rightful
owner after the day is saved Kimberly
makes the choice to stay with the
Rangers instead of pursuing her
gymnastics career however the other
Rangers and Zora I'm convinced her this
is a once-in-a-lifetime opportunity and
she relents that left only one person
deserving enough to take the place
[Music]
how I going right now
Kimberly may have played the damsel in
distress for Tommy a few too many times
but overall she matured into a strong
character they got the send-off she
deserved in a three parter that is among
the best in the series but so stupid you
sound stupid many pickles in her color
how about three number four attack the
green with evil sada
and the green candle parts one and two
from season one in green with evil Rita
decides to give the sixth power coin to
the new savvy martial artist from Angel
Grove High named Tommy under her control
he becomes the Green Ranger and is
bestowed with powers that the five main
Rangers can't handle tommy nearly
destroys the command center severing the
Rangers connection to Zordon and puts
alpha five out of commission as things
go from bad to worse the Power Rangers
must find a way to stop Tommy and free
him from Rita's influence in the green
candle Tommy had been with the Rangers
for a while but Rita has a plan to
return his Green Ranger powers to her
forever through magic wax that Tommy
touched well under the evil spell of
Rita a candle is formed and lit due to
its connection to Tommy's powers when it
melts all the way down Tommy will cease
being a ranger led by Jason the team
makes an attempt to retrieve the candle
but runs into other problems when Rita
sends down the cyclops monster to attack
angel Grove and its current lone
protector top let me just say get used
to this a lot of great MMPR episodes are
multi-part Green with Eve there's not
much to say I can't not have it on the
list and it's the most memorable thing
about the show Tommy's introduction and
the initial evil Green Ranger arc is
something people still talk about in
pretty great detail my thoughts on it
are pretty much your thoughts on it
Tommy is amazing the Green Ranger became
an unbelievably popular character and it
all stemmed from this massive five-part
all right now come off in time Tarasov
saber-tooth Tiger Tyrannosaurus yeah now
what I thought was just as it's not more
interesting from a story slash character
perspective was the fallout from Greene
with evil and Tommy joining the Power
Rangers the green candle two-parter
handled Tommy's first exit from the show
and a compelling way that kept him a hot
commodity less was more I always loved
the friendship between Jason and Tamy
they were equals in many ways and we got
to see a role reversal when Jason
returned as the gold Ranger in Power
Rangers Zeo here Jason is willing to do
anything to save his friend but comes up
short it's a failure that had long
lasting consequences when the candle
burns out the only way for RIA to not
have control the Green Ranger power was
for Tommy to give his power coin to
another ranger he chooses Jason and
whenever the red Rangers summon the
Green Rangers powers it made for a
badass moment it's been great Tommy
don't worry I'll be all right
[Music]
so what I'm giving Tommy the props he
deserved was also very memorable you are
a strong already quite referring writer
and an honorable man Kimberly and
Tommy's kiss at the end of the episode
is also a moment that stood out it
started a relationship that lasted until
Kimberly departure in season three I
[Music]
wanted you that for a long time hey I
don't need a melting candle to kick your
ass
wait wait wait Rob wait wait what can I
interest you in some character
development
number three missing green from season
two after Tommy permanently loses his
green ranger powers Jason is still
feeling guilty about not retrieving the
green candle which would have stopped
Tommy's power loss when Zak
Kimberly Trini and Billy are captured by
gold are similar candles are created
that are stealing their powers with
Jason alone he's forced to fight Lord
Zedd Piper a monster and save his
friends all by himself the follow up
from the green candle is still being
felt here in the following season after
time he loses his green ranger powers
for good
Jason blames himself he questions his
role as a leader and friend in an
episode that's pretty rare for the first
three seasons for the first real time we
see Jason get thrown off and on his own
a character flaws that shows up every
once in a while is his anger here that's
a dress the Red Ranger has to control
himself after what happened to Tommy
also happens to the other four Rangers
they're trapped with their powers being
taken away Jason is the only one who can
save them however things get worse when
the pipe brain monster is let loose on
Angel Grove this is where Zordon comes
in great rager
tongue stand before me Jason a true
leader is always faced with tough
decisions
he must control his emotions and act
based on who has the greatest need so
Ron's pep talk works because Jason
single-handedly destroys pipe brain
beats up Goldar and saves the Rangers
once again you have proven yourself to
be a formidable leader you are awesome
the circle completes at the end when we
see a secluded Tommy writing a letter to
Jason look I don't blame you for what
happened I never did just keep your head
together the others depend on you so do
i we'll see each other it gives to it
it's a great episode of the show that
had some strong character moments for
the Red Ranger the only thing holding it
back upon a rewatch is that Austin st.
John was already gone from the show when
this episode was in post-production so
he didn't voice Jason when he was more
it's noticeable as is his silence in his
battle with pipe rain other than that
though
it's a top notch edition of the show
that sounds just like a lot SEPA so what
time we're comeback
number two return of the Green Ranger
parts one through three from season two
Rida seeks the aid of The Wizard of
deception who devises the plan to clone
Tommy now the white ranger as the new
evil Green Ranger that will serve their
sinister interests and finally take out
the genuine article as Tommy's isolated
flooding his clone and The Wizard of
deception the other Rangers are
transported back in time to 18th century
angel Grove with no way back the White
Ranger has to rescue his team all while
fending off his dangerous dogging it's
the impossible matchup we never thought
we'd see the white ranger versus the
Green Ranger the dragon Zord versus the
Tigers or this fight didn't disappoint
[Music]
with the
now admittedly the B story with the
Rangers in the 1700s was pretty dumb
they don't really try and make time
treble work in the show but hey it's
Power Rangers there's a scene here where
evil Green Ranger enters the command
center and has a face-to-face loads
Horta recommend to go which is done with
the Power Rangers let's just say
wherever they are history is repeating
itself I warn you if any morally come to
the aisle did sort of just threaten him
hell yes they react in the dragon Zord
in these episodes and his entrance is
great
[Music]
after Tommy defeats the wizard of
deception his clone is freed from a
spell and together they fixed the pass
that the wizard sent in to havoc
Tommy's clone decides to live out the
rest of his life in the past and I'm
assuming he retained his Green Ranger
powers it's an interesting decision
however it played out the fact that we
got to see a full-on fight with the
green and white Rangers is an amazing
moment for the show
[Music]
those all sound awful
lost Cara let's pinched it finally
something we can agree on and the number
one best Mighty Morphin Power Rangers
episode is changing of the Zords parts 1
through 3 from season 3
Rita's teenage pawn catherine befriends
the rangers in steals kimberlly's power
coin
she then infiltrates tom with falcon
Zord and takes control of it for lord
zedd which allows ninja to be captured
by the evil duo with Kimberly's coin in
the hands of evil
she starts fading and is eventually
captured by gold r4 Zedd and Rita having
all the leverage that presents a deal to
the Rangers they pilot the new Shogun
Zords which that has control of as they
destroy Angel Grove or Kimberley will
come to harm
facing the odds stacked against them
like never before the team has to find a
way to save Kimberley and somehow take
control of the Shogun Zords
before they reduce their city to ashes
there are a lot of reasons why this
three-parter takes the top spot I think
what gets me most about it are the
stakes that are involved Kimberly's
power coin is stolen in the first part
and she could literally die because of
it minge aura is also taken prisoner by
Zed and the Falcon sword is abducted the
good guys are losing pretty badly to
make things even bleaker we see Kats
first attempt at breaking Rita's evil
hold over her we see that she was an
innocent before Rita to control as a bad
guy Kat is very effective she's the main
reason the Rangers are in such a
predicament they're just a lot of great
moments sprinkled throughout these three
episodes
I love the bulk and skull baywatch
parody
you
[Music]
this entrance from the Rangers is one of
the coolest things I've seen on the show
[Music]
also I know this may be annoying to some
people but I love ninjord voice don't
let me expect you
after Kimberly is kidnapped the Rangers
realize what serious trouble they're in
and then
maybe the best moment in the entire
series that's offered to the Rangers
involves them destroying angel Grove and
the new Zords he's controlling or he's
pretty much going to kill Kimberly it's
an impossible ultimatum for the Rangers
and we see them actually consider taking
des offer they come pretty close in part
three we even see a fight between Zed
and Tommy one-on-one you can feel the
tension photos high odds really
necessary yeah bet you do you are going
to be sorry yourself getting Kimberly
back was the main concern here and it
made these episodes feel special her
exit in a different shade of pink proved
that the third season could have a
strong grasp of storytelling leading
into Zeo speaking of which I put up the
pole on my Twitter at awesome underscore
Walter and you guys voted yes so keep an
eye out for the top-five best / worst
episodes a Power Rangers Zeo coming in
the near future fine fine fine fine fine
you like it so much maybe there's
something to it I mean Who am I to judge
I think twisters better than the Dark
Knight agree to disagree
yeah fine whatever Oh power down oh oh
oh oh I gotta do some Dino carne oh well
it's a it's been fun
sucks times infinity
[Music]
you